hi I put up a video in a law back giving
general advice on applying to Oxford
Cambridge and as a result of that I
asked our choir will contact me
those people are asking about tips on
flying about interviews one thing the
can of a lot was people asking me for my
interview questions I thought I go
through each of my interviews each of
the questions break down the weather
asking how I answered it and in most
cases our ship answered it this isn't
actually going to be a really physically
based video but what I wanted to do is
just work through interviews like given
account of how interviews power kind of
questions you can expect and it is
possible across to loves other subjects
so I hope you find it useful the
interview one my shoe clarified er how I
apply to Jesus college and the first
interior happens on the day I arrived
which was my physics based Instagram
dreams news of Jesus one was physics one
was maths and mum was meant to be an
experimental based ones but well do
Planet X the first question that they
asked me was I've sat down and they kind
of weren't really listening to I said
whether it has Y in physics might here
and give a general account was what was
nice to do the kind of stock answer Expo
and in a way they're kind of like good
cop bad cop one interview didn't appear
very interested the other kind of jumps
on one thing I said I said I want to be
an astronaut he said like dirtiest be a
pipe and like is quite aggressive from
here the first main question they asked
me was how can we tell there are planets
around distant stars
to which I replied that you can see a
gravitation wall the star moves in its
orbit what causes that model the answer
being that when you have two bodies
orbiting each other like the Earth and
Sun the earth doesn't actually go around
the center of Sun they go around their
center of mass of the system so it's
somewhere very close potentially fun so
the results that the Sun it's rotating
about point is not yet centered so it
cannot have a slight change like that if
you beautiful inside the next question
was why can't we see these planets
through a tough and
become obvious answer to the science of
our small inspectors really really
really big let on to the last question
which is why do we increase the size of
the mirror in a subject I gave the
answer so that you increase the river
because that allows you to take in more
light obviously the more light you can
get like as far away than we can tell
these or they really envision them and I
struggle together until the very end
with that any image that's formed by a
telescope because it's essentially just
a long tube it's going to be diffraction
limited you're going to get the fraction
around the edge test there so if we
increase the mirror family then you can
get less fraction critical or
aperture so the last question this ship
with the district which shows two
because one of which is the cylindrical
knowledge of Congress and a on a seesaw
equidistant from fulcrum so both
standards the idea is they both have the
same cross-sectional area on the bottom
and I both still it's the same right
have water so they asked me which one
which side of the seesaw goes down those
yes it was this side Christa's more
water the less volume said right okay
mnemonics passes said to me right I'm
going to tell you a different idea if
force is pressure times area and the
both have the same cross sectional area
and they both at the same level of water
which means the pressure is the same at
the bottom that should mean that they're
balanced but you just tell me that one
second to go down so are you right or am
i right
and I had to think for a while I know
the correct answer is that the reason
this night does go down is because on
this side you have a vertical component
of the normal force on the beaker so you
have normal force going like this
and that's not horizontal he have a
small component the firstly and then the
net for girls and for math counteract
the same pressure acting them so because
this side doesn't have doesn't have that
happy hour that's why I talked about and
then the last question they asked me was
how are you demonstrated because of us
couldn't only with in a classroom
respective tools and they wanted me to
say I didn't there that you could use a
drill drill hole and then you have the
water will just going to eventually you
come up and they're like interview you
to I solve locked out an entity to you
that is it was meant to be based on your
experimental logbook which I do in keep
is school we didn't write Stephanie we
just in experiments town we just didn't
scraps of paper as soon as I mentioned
that in the preliminary meeting we all
have together napkins everyone plate so
it doesn't really look good from the off
but instead of that that it means to be
just based to my personal statement
which was good because it meant like a
place a lot of strengths I have the
ignant physics like why did my work
experience sporting of like speaking
that kind of thing
but it was bad in the sense that I
really didn't have that experience and
experimentation which I thought I had as
a tender personal interview is actually
one of the clues and Charles for doing
it's practical course so other people
who did happen to be based on these
their experiments were what was your
favorite experiment you've done can you
recall a particular experiment and talk
us through how you did it one that I
think is how would you establish the
standing wave pattern in a clarinet I
have no idea how that fits in there